- What is going on?
The second and third largest bank failures
in U.S. history happened
in a three-day period,
and it's got investors, regulators,
and bank customers
understandably concerned.
There is still a lot of
information we don't have
about the collapse of Signature
Bank, Silicon Valley Bank,
and others, but what we do know
is there's plenty of reason to have faith
that the U.S. banking system will be okay.
Unfortunately, there's also
plenty of reason to worry
that some of the issues
that brought down Signature
and SVB could be evidence of
a bigger systemic problem.
I'll explain.
First, let's talk about
the big picture risks.
Silicon Valley Bank was invested in many
of the same assets as other large banks,
U.S. treasuries,
mortgage-backed securities,
and other bonds that
have seen big declines
in value over the past year.
Those are actually the safe assets
that the Federal Reserve
requires banks to hold.
Many banks are invested in things
with much higher risk
profiles like stocks,
leveraged loans and derivatives.
Those have also seen big losses,
and banks often use borrowed
money to make those investments
in an effort to increase their returns.
The Fed lowered the reserve
requirement ratio for banks
to zero in March 2020 and
has still not raised it,
meaning banks that hold
billions in deposits
can hold as little as $40 million in cash.
U.S. banks had unrealized losses
of more than $600 billion
at the end of 2022,
and things haven't gotten much
better in markets since then.
If depositors start to
demand their money back,
lots of these Banks
could need to sell assets
at a loss to meet those demands
or they might try to raise money
through stock or bond sales like SVB did,
and that could lead to
more runs on more banks,
but there is some good news.
Banks have stronger regulations
than they did before the
global financial crisis.
The nation's largest
banks are regularly put
through so-called stress tests by the Fed
to determine whether they
could withstand a crisis,
and the U.S. banks determine
to be systemically important
have all passed.
There's also a lot more money
deposited in fewer banks now.
Between 2010 and 2020,
the number of banking
institutions dropped by almost 30%
and the five biggest
banks now hold nearly half
of all FDIC-insured deposits.
That's not necessarily
great for consumer choice,
but it does mean that the
bigger banks are better able
to fortify themselves
against short-term panic
and market losses to stay in business.
Another reason to think
that this is not a wide-ranging problem
is that Silicon Valley Bank had what folks
on Wall Street called
idiosyncratic problems,
meaning issues that were unique to them.
As its name suggests, Silicon Valley Bank
did a lot of business with
venture capital firms, startups,
and others in Silicon Valley,
home of the U.S. tech industry.
Tech investment has
gotten battered this year
as investors have been spooked
by tumbling stock prices.
The Fed's rate hiking cycle
has been especially damaging
for shares of tech companies,
because many are relying
on making profits far off in the future.
Higher interest rates today
eat into those potential future profits
and make tech companies
look less valuable.
Plus, it costs more for
venture capital firms
and other investors to borrow money
to put into these companies
that are not turning a
profit in many cases,
so many of the firms and individuals
who had money held in
SVB were taking it out
rather than putting more in.
SVB also had invested
big in mortgage debt,
much of it coming at
the top of the market,
and home prices have generally
lost value since then,
and the bank purchased
limited market hedges
like swaps that could
have reduced their losses
in the event of big downturns
like the ones we've seen.
So are we in for more trouble?
There's no way to know for
sure, but if you've got less
than $250,000 in an
FDIC-insured bank account,
there's no reason to take your money out.
As we've seen recently, that's
insured by the government,
and even if banks fail,
depositors below the
limit will be made whole.
(pleasant synth music)